To be clear in your mind.
Yeah.
In what you intend to achieve.
No.
What you are going to do that doesn't seem like too much to ask.
Certainly in war
and you wouldn't think it would be too much for people to ask in their lives
either.
They're precious lives as precious as these 58,000
that died in Vietnam.
Yeah.
Heroes.
But how often do we see people going through their lives without knowing what
they are trying to do without having any intent,
without having a clear mission.
I'm talking to on an individual level as a person,
people go through their lives without knowing what it is they want to do,
what they want to accomplish.
So know what your mission is,
know what your intent as the commander of your life,
know what your intent is and then fight with everything you've got
to win.
Okay.
Yeah,
and I think that's,
Oh,
I've got for tonight,
so,
okay.
Deco,
maybe if you want to
shed some light on how people can
maybe help themselves when that war.
Sure.
And maybe support the podcast if they want to.
They want to.
Yeah.
That point though,
in my opinion is a good on a,
it's a good one.
It's a good way to think about you.
People go through their lives,
I don't even know what they're trying to do.
Yeah.
And it sounds the same thing as going to war without knowing what the outcome is
supposed to be.
Yeah.
Your goal.
But it sounds kind of like a bs when you say it,
you know like hey go through.
You know when you go through life,
should you have a goal,
a real obvious yes.
I can say no,
you shouldn't have a goal kind of thing.
So it seems obvious but you know how you live day to day.
You,
you know,
you might have a goal for the day,
maybe two,
maybe three,
but Brett life is for life to the full spectrum of we'll,
we'll get it so shocking.
Cause what you're saying is absolutely true.
You wouldn't think that people would be going through life without knowing where
they're trying to get to.
Yeah.
But you wouldn't think that a nation would go to war without clear intention of
where they want to end up.
And how they're going to get there.
At least an idea of how you're gonna get there.
Now I have a little bit of luck when Klaus Fitz says how you're going to conduct
the war.
That's not necessarily true because you don't know.
You can't know how you're going to conduct a war before the war starts.
You can have an idea but you can't know fully.
Just like if you were to say,
Hey,
my goal is to x in my life.
You don't know how you're going to be able to do that.
Yeah.
Cause you talking about cause you gotta adjust [inaudible] going to make it an
adaptation is things are going to come up.
Things are gonna Change.
The battlefield changes,
your life changes,
things pop up.
I mean things happen.
So I think that that idea that you're going to know how you're going to execute
something is,
is farfetched.
I think actually I should use the word idea.
You should have an idea of how you're going to do it.
Yeah.
You just have an idea like okay,
well this is what I need to get done.
This is what I want to achieve in my life.
I want to make,
I want to do this.
What's a simple one?
I want to own a house.
That's a simple one.
That's a good place to start.
I want to own a house.
Okay,
well let's think about how we're going to get there.
You know,
that's let's,
let's think about how we're going to get there.
You have to build your credit.
You have to,
how do you build your credit?
you have to borrow money.
Some people,
somebody would go to buy a house.
They've never borrowed money before.
You can't borrow money if you've never borrowed money.
You can't borrow money for a house if you've never borrowed money for a car or a
or a or some smaller object before.
So you've got to establish your credit.
Then you've got to have two years worth of income.
Then you've got to have a big fat down,
sitting ready.
So there's things you've got to do this thinking now.
Now that might change along the way.
The idea is that you've got to move towards that goal.
But that's what was so nice about hearing the Vietnamese commander's intent.
Get close,
split them up,
boom.
You go make that happen.
Hey,
guess what?
Do you want to buy a house one day?
Save money.
Have good credit.
Yeah.
Okay,
well you gotta make money.
How you gonna make money?
You might make it drive an Uber.
You might make it delivering pizza.
You might make,
cause you got your real job,
but that's supporting your family.
But then you need a little extra to throw in there.
Well,
that's why you end up driving Uber or you end up with whatever it is you're
going to do.
Are you ready?
We're gonna make some money on the side that you can start stashing away.
Yeah.
And at the end of the day,
you do have that goal,
you know?
So it is,
yeah.
How you conduct yourself.
It's not gonna be cut and dry for sure.
But you know,
in these examples,
like,
uh,
you know,
you want to buy a house,
that's a goal.
That's a specific goal.
But that's just one teeny tiny goal in life.
If you're only,
of course you're not going to run into somebody who their only goal in life is
to buy a house.
No,
no,
no.
I said a civil one except some people like,
Hey,
don't buy a house.
It's stupid.
You should rent them themselves.
That's fine.
I'm not telling everyone what their goal should be.
And if you want to keep renting,
keep renting.
Maybe that's for you.
Yeah.
Fully.
Not for me yet.
But maybe it's for you.
There's other things you want to put your money.
That's cool.
You're doing some other something else smart with your money.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Like public buying rims or something like either way though.
If you,
uh,
consider like just what went classic cause of it's how you see the name.
What did he saying and compare it to life,
right?
Where buying house.
Sure.
That's one of many goals you're going to have in life because life is full.
Like I said,
but so it kind of,
when you really think about it by it's hard.
It's hard to like designate some specific goals.
And then that's all you're going to do.
Okay.
Let's say you're to,
you're going to say you're going to be financially secure and independent.
Okay.
That would be a much bigger goss.
Yeah.
That's an awesome goal to have.
And the younger you make that goal,
the better chance you have of achieving it.
Yeah.
Cause now you're not wasting your money.
You're actually saving for house so you can get that house paid off.
So now you don't have a mortgage anymore.
You know,
he's like,
yeah,
that's a bigger goal.
That's a broader goal.
Just like when you,
when you go to a war,
you need to know what it is you're going to war for.
What are you going to do and when are you going to stop and what's your intended
result?
Yeah.
So you get to,
in a way,
you got to fill your life with a bunch of goals.
You don't get gym.
Cause like if you have small goals that lead to the big goal,
right?
So for instance,
you want to be financially secure and stable,
what are you going to do?
You're going to save some of your money.
Okay.
That's one thing.
You're going to buy a house.
That's another thing.
You're going to pay off your car and you're not going to buy expensive dumb
cars.
You're going to buy cheap cars until you have the money to buy them with cash.
You know you're going to make all these little things.
You're going to work extra,
you're gonna,
you know you're going to do these things.
So you're right.
You have,
you have your broad goal.
Yes.
You have your longterm goal.
And then you've got your short term goals that lead and are strategically
aligned with that longterm goal.
It's the same thing in war.
You have to have those,
both those things going on.